welcome to this video playing get Chanel
on Germany meaning goes quickly eh now
on or works quickly could also be a
possible translation so what do we have
here the Zurich variation of the news oh
and down this is a sideline with early
51 of the side lines that are available
the idea is here to play for a quick f5
so I go prepare a 5 immediately this
position type is one of them positions
positions where the two bishops are a
long term factor but at the moment why
it is not really benefiting much from
from leadership especially the c3 bishop
which is the additional bishop and the
one that should prove its superiority to
a knight and the bishop is not doing
much anything much at the moment so now
I can hmm yeah I can but should I mm-hmm
I can just get everything exchange
everything on you form i think it's it's
okay for black maybe not the most
ambitious way to play but a good way to
play
some instant activity I wonder I wonder
I wonder night F 594 is this a
possibility it looks it looks like an
active plan trying to activate the night
I could also have played night g6 would
have been okay as well okay so Kareem
can I can I go Queen h4 even on g3 play
notes no one idea is not it's not
possible even g3 rock g4
hmm
I'm always tempted by Queen edge form to
know this but not if you watched my
videos on g3 antonucci form maybe this
is just too crude what I'm doing here
but it isn't it's interesting I mean
it's not clear that it is a bad idea I
have active pieces lined up here against
the king f three act play 93 and I 10
just Luke evade or queen esri just
getting more pieces to into the game
tween age three and then night H force
even though it's even dangerous and I
don't know maybe this isn't this isn't
done this isn't bad at all for black it
looked a bit a bit too risky or somewhat
strange to me but maybe it is okay
some of the pieces look a bit loose the
not f5 is not protected and the green
edge for is only covered due to the pin
so it looks like y'all always this
impression that there's maybe some some
technical trick that that refutes this
but it's not at all easy for wide I mean
there are many ways to go wrong here
let's say king h multiplied loop g3 fg3
not g3 winning the queen if he goes King
g2 there's at least queen age five
retina group g3 so King moves are not
working if you move the F part a plane I
g3 and I just threaten Queen h3 and
night H form going to going on you too
yeah that's route g3 here and unless he
has got some brilliant response to that
that i'm missing gathers also that the
bishop hanging so it's probably not a
problem playable but playable is an
understatement it's a it's very good it
doesn't have move
mm okay please to maybe like resign I
quadro Gary no it's just that it's just
lost yeah it seems that right here white
is in trouble yeah the computer already
gives black a very big edge here I'm
surprised I was I was thinking that this
okay it's a typical kind of blitz
approach put the pieces near the enemy
King but it's really good in the
synthesis a case and it really fits the
name gage now what this really went went
rather quickly downhill hmm strange yeah
but I have substantial counter play with
that five-year this is clear here i
briefly considered night g6 also um
motif more worth remembering here 96
also an idea the ideas if it takes then
night f4 is good attacking here and it's
intending to take so you will always get
the the f5 porn back but I'm at first
taking him so this also was interesting
this there's this reply though in that
it's not so clear that your night is
well-positioned you can go here though
intending this kind of Moses was so was
a good alternative but this should
should lead to a satisfactory position
Bishop detours right here after that
yeah probably g3 is not good and now
it's in trouble yeah we add this really
Amelie window and down
yeah thanks for watching